[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN MAEDA: Hello, everybody.
Wow, this is a nice stage.
OK, well, I am
delighted to be here.
I have a clock.
We're going to get the see
Hannah a Beachler after me,
so that's going to
be super awesome.
I am the warm-up act.
I'm John Maeda.
Good to see all of you.
This is something I
made three years ago.
Does anyone know this TV show?
No, we don't know this TV show.
Well, I spoke at the 50th
anniversary of "Star Trek",
and it was a true honor.
But I really didn't think
about "Star Trek" lot
until that moment.
And I made this image
and I showed it.
And people were asking
me why am I Scotty?
And I was like, well,
Scotty is an engineer,
and I wanted to be an engineer.
And I was asked, well, why
not Sulu, because he's Asian?
And I said, I don't
want to be Sulu.
I want to be Scotty.
I want to be an engineer.
But it was in that
moment I realized
the reason why I
didn't want to be Sulu
is because I thought he was
weird, in the sense that I
thought it was strange
how Sulu didn't
speak with some kind of
thick Asian accent on TV.
And I thought that's weird.
Something is wrong with him.
And it always stuck
with me, why did
I think it was wrong that he
sounded like a Californian?
I never thought of
it until that moment.
And that's the general
topic of this presentation.
Now, if you have a question
and you got introvert,
just text me your question--
253-217-4017-- and we'll
be able to interact.
Because the problem with this
kind of conversation thing
is it isn't a conversation.
It's like a one-way thing.
So go ahead and text me a
question at 253-217-4017.
And I'm watching the clock.
OK, here we go.
The Design in Tech Reports--
there's four of them
now and they're long,
so you can read them in
the micro-type, et cetera.
The big conclusion
after four years of work
has been to ask questions
about how can design in tech
be more inclusive.
If we can figure
this out, we can
unlock incredible possibility
and profitability.
The problem with
the word design,
however, is that it
means too many things.
So the report defines design
as three kinds of design.
There's classical design,
like your glasses.
There's design thinking-- this
idea of using Post-it notes
to create structure of ideas.
And there's
computational design--
the kind of design that
is powered by Moore's law.
It's a different kind of design.
It uses a material that
didn't exist 100 years ago.
What's a computational designer?
I've defined this as
roughly four type of things
you have to have as a
computational designer.
You don't have to
know how to program,
but you have to be
technically literate.
You also have to think
critically about technology.
For you, technology
is a responsibility.
So you wonder how
things are being used.
You also use all
kinds of design.
You aren't stuck in just
computational design.
And lastly, you're very
curious about new things,
because designers loved
to learn new people,
new customs, new anything
because it's how they learn.
So designers aren't
inherently diversity positive.
It's a very important point.
Now, if you think about
the value of design,
it's been demonstrated
by all the M&A activity--
the Mergers and
Acquisition activity--
of agencies.
So I reported on this
report, over 20 agencies
were acquired by
consulting companies,
because consulting companies
are finding value in design
for their clients,
which is a big deal.
It never happened before.
Now, the problem, however,
is that classical designers
tend to dis design thinking.
You know what I'm talking about?
Like oh, design thinkers,
they have the Post-it notes
and the Sharpie markers
with the white board.
You know, classical
designers don't think of them
as real designers.
But I always tell
classical designers, well,
they make more
money than you do.
So important to note, design
thinking is not a bad thing.
It's a different kind of design.
Also, I found that, being in
the Silicon Valley for a while,
we tend to forget there's
the rest of the world.
So I'm a big fan of China
and all of the design
work being done there--
design of cars, design of
experiences, especially mobile,
and, more recently, using AI
to design banners, designs.
They're just so further
ahead that many people
seem to have the impression
in the United States.
And that's kind of an
embarrassing problem.
Also, the other problem
I've seen in tech
is that it indexes to
younger people, which
is a great opportunity.
But there's also an incredible
opportunity in the older
generation because, I don't
know if you all know this,
but you all will get older.
Yeah, it's not a problem.
It's a real thing.
And as you get
older, things change.
The first thing that
changes is your eyesight.
So for all designers
who love 6.5 point,
you better give it up.
Looks awesome,
especially in light,
but you won't be able to see
it once you hit 40-something.
And at Automattic we call
this the bolder generation.
Get it?
Boulder?
We liked that.
Good news is that design
is being used sooner
in the process.
It used to be in tech that
you'd make the technology,
and oh, my gosh,
it finally works.
And you'd spray design
on called make it pretty.
That was great 10 years ago,
but because the competition
is so fierce now, you have to
bake design into the product.
And you can see globally-- we
did a survey of 2,000 people--
the trend is design
is being used
earlier in the process,
which is a big deal.
Now, when we talk about
computational design,
however, it's important to note
that computational design uses
the computer.
And if you were-- who
was there in the '80s?
'80s, '80s, come on.
'80s people, right?
People didn't like people who
used the computer for design,
right?
You were made fun of like
Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer.
You were a bad designer because
you were using the computer.
There was a time.
But the computer kept on
getting more interesting.
It came out of prints.
It became interactive.
Who remembers
Macromedia Director?
Macro mind.
Come on.
Yes, yes.
This stuff has been happening
for a long time-- interaction
design.
More recently have these
tools gotten more interesting,
specifically by
integrating things
like machine intelligence.
We can all feel it
coming and that's
kind of exciting, but also
scary at the same time.
Let's see here.
OK, so when we think about
machine intelligence,
my favorite demo--
and this is all sourcing
real data off the internet--
this is Siri saying
something in iOS 9.
SIRI: 1 liter is
33.81 fluid ounces.
JOHN MAEDA: This is iOS 10.
SIRI: 1 liter is
33.81 fluid ounces.
JOHN MAEDA: This is iOS 11.
SIRI: 1 liter is
33.81 fluid ounces.
JOHN MAEDA: Got really
good fast, didn't it?
That's what's happened.
These quantum leaps
are occurring.
Linearity is being thrown out,
and that's really important.
And so when people
ask in design,
should I learn all these things?
If you don't learn them,
you'll be left behind.
And so it's so key to
stay at the forefront.
Now, I also had this question--
when do you expect AI to
replace most visual designers?
And it's interesting
because the average
says at least five years till
visual designers get replaced--
not everyone, of course,
but some design jobs.
I think it's going to
be much sooner, quite
frankly, because all the
information from companies
like Google, and companies
in China as well,
are that a lot of
rote things can be
done by machine intelligence.
Here's some of my favorites.
I love that you can
remove the watermark.
I wonder why you'd
want to do that.
You can perfect contrast.
This is MIT work.
Making a dark image
an awesome image.
It can also take two photos and
make a new photo out of them
too.
This is work from Nvidia.
You can also generate infinite
variations of ideas, just
with pattern libraries
in machine intelligence.
You can also-- as you all
know in this audience,
at least-- you can
change people's faces.
And you can fix drawings.
What's important
to note, though,
is that we see these warnings.
Consider the photos, that's
how you tell if it's fake.
But it's so hard to tell if
things are a fake these days.
And soon it's going to
get harder and harder.
So we are human beings we
like to mess with the machine.
So this is one of
my favorite things.
If you click on
this button, this
will like randomly hit things,
so your browser gets confused.
So we humans love to confuse
machine intelligence.
You know, put a pixel there.
I don't know what it is anymore,
says machine intelligence.
So we'll keep looking
for this to try
to stop the inevitable,
which is that computers
are learning so quickly.
And when they learn so
quickly, they learn bad things.
I'm not sure if you remember
it, but in July 2015,
the Wall Street
Journal reported how
images mistakenly tagged
black people as gorillas
was happening in 2015.
The algorithm was fixed.
Why did it exist?
Because the database had more
light faces than darker faces,
so the database was dumb.
And so these data dumbness is
occurring all over the place
as machine intelligence
ingests more data which
contains incredible
biases that we have,
unfortunately, let sit
out there for too long.
So how do we change that?
I think we change that by
rethinking a few things.
And that is where does
technology evolve the quickest?
And in the report, we pointed
out that there's two regions.
Do you see the red
regions-- the hot regions?
That's where all this
stuff is happening--
this region of the country--
New York.
But if you flip the map,
this is a map of inequality--
income inequality.
If you flip it, you
see the exact opposite.
That where tech is
not impacting is
where poverty is growing the
quickest, because the skills
gap is so large.
This audience here is
probably in the 0.01%
of the most advanced
people in the world.
That said, the entire world
is behind in computation,
understanding the
impact of Moore's law.
And this is a very subtle
intellectual privilege problem
today.
So when we look at what
technology has done,
it's been able to be
extremely smart at optimizing
our experience, and
therefore making nothing
we understand real or not real.
And that we all know it's
happening, and it's amazing,
but it's also quite disturbing.
My mother-- by the way--
her favorite newspaper
is the "National
Enquirer," so I'm always
checking out the headlines.
I just picked this up.
Look out, Google.
They know too.
So is the digital
divide related somehow
to poverty and inequality?
I think it's hard to say
they're related or it's causal
or correlated, but there's
something connected that we
cannot miss.
And that is that if you don't
have access to computation,
you are excluded.
And if you don't understand
what it can do, you're excluded.
And so technology keeps
shooting off without them, us.
So what's a solution?
I'm passionate
about remote work.
I'm at a company that is
all remote, Automattic.
Who remotes-- who
works remotely?
That's quite a few.
So remote work is neat
because it takes you out
of these bubbles of tech.
I guess I'm hopeful
that's at Automattic
we're trying figure out
a world where WordPress
is good design for all.
How do we do that?
We have to use the fact
that we can go anywhere
because we're remote.
So for instance, let's see--
someone, I was
visiting Appalachia.
And in Appalachia
I heard the story
about how it was a coal
miner who's teaching code
to ex-coal miners.
And he said, you
know, you people
are from the
three-dimensional world.
You're 3D.
You live in cities
with skyscrapers.
And if you're from a smaller
city, you're in a town,
you live in 2D.
In 2D, you have no
skyscrapers, just streets.
And he said, here in
Appalachia, we live in 1D.
There's one street, and
we all live off of it.
That's when I realized the
neat thing about remote work
is you're zero-dimensional.
And by being zero-dimensional,
you can travel anywhere.
And so we're trying
to use this advantage
to go into all kinds of
places, anywhere in the world,
and to connect with people.
And I can tell you that this
experience of being remote
is a very powerful way
to reduce exclusion,
because you can be including
by just going anywhere
you think is necessary.
Now, this is my favorite quote
by the lawyer Verna Myers.
"Diversity is being
invited to the party.
Inclusion is being
asked to dance."
Say this over to yourself.
It's such a powerful idea,
because if you don't have both,
nothing occurs.
And so when you ask how
to be more inclusive,
it's quite easy.
Just ask where do
you spend your time?
Who do you hang out with?
Look at the people in
the room around you?
Are they diverse in some way?
If they're not, you're
going to have to do
something terrible to yourself.
You're going to have to
make yourself uncomfortable.
And it's exciting
to be uncomfortable.
Oh, my gosh, you say
the dumbest things.
And you stumble, and
you become stupid,
and you become smarter and
a better person through it,
I believe.
So all of you who are not found
yourself in this way, enjoy it.
It's so exciting.
I'm a big entertainment
fan, and I've
been tracking all
the movies that
have put diversity inclusion
at the center of them.
And they're doing
very well financially.
Movies like "Wonder Woman,"
directed by Patty Jenkins,
"Star Wars" had a much more
diverse cast, "The Foreigner"
by Jackie Chan.
Who's seen "The Foreigner,"
where the terrorists aren't
dark-skinned people?
That was brand new.
And "The Big Sick," of course.
And these are doing
really well financially.
This is teaching machine
intelligence and the business
world that this is a
pattern to take note of.
I like Kumail Nanjiani's
quote, "there's so
many movies from
different points of view
that are making a ton of money.
Don't do it because it's better
for society and representation,
even though it is.
Do it because you'll get rich.
You'll get that
promotion, right?"
This thinking
seems crass, yet it
sits at the center of how
change will start to occur.
And I believe that as we see
more of these kinds of things,
wonderful things will happen.
I want to close on my mother
went to see "Black Panther."
This was her review.
It went kind of viral.
"Hi, John.
Just came back from
seeing 'Black Panther.'
It was very good."
And we actually went to see
"Avengers" last, me and mom.
I was in Seattle.
And my mom is like 83 years old.
She's like a little
woman with her cane.
We're walking out of "Avengers"
and I said, mom, how was it?
"Oh, it wasn't as good as
'Black Panther.'" So anyways,
thank you.
And we'll have Hannah next,
so please stay seated.
[APPLAUSE]
HANNAH BEACHLER: This is nuts.
Look at all the faces.
JOHN MAEDA: Wow, I'm so happy.
I get to interview
Hannah Beachler.
Yes.
HANNAH BEACHLER: Yeah, right.
Hey, y'all.
Good to be here.
And this thing is
a little weird,
so you might see me kind
of being a little weird.
JOHN MAEDA: So how's it been
walking around this area?
HANNAH BEACHLER: I'm sorry?
JOHN MAEDA: How's it been
walking around, wandering,
looking around?
HANNAH BEACHLER: Cool.
We went and hung out
at the auditorium,
and walked around
some of the tents,
and ate, and sat on the
grass, and it was fabulous.
JOHN MAEDA: Anything
catch your attention?
HANNAH BEACHLER: I mean, I was
just looking at everything.
The area is
beautiful, and I think
everything has been great.
I've been talking to some great
people, and it's been awesome.
JOHN MAEDA: So my mother
loved "Black Panther."
I'm sure you weren't
surprised, though.
HANNAH BEACHLER:
What, I'm sorry?
JOHN MAEDA: I'm sure
you weren't surprised.
HANNAH BEACHLER: That
your mother loved it?
Not really.
You know honestly, that was
part of what we tried to do,
was make it so
everybody could love it.
It wasn't really geared
towards one specific anything.
It was more about creating
a feeling and a moment.
And you know what I mean?
I am pretty into my emotions.
I would call myself an
emotionalist, if you will.
And that's really
what drives me,
is creating things from a place
that people can relate to,
and then that expands.
JOHN MAEDA: Had you
heard of "Black Panther"
when you got the job?
HANNAH BEACHLER: Yes, I did.
I had heard of the
character and the comics,
and I kind of knew it
because I knew Marvel.
I've certainly asked
my son right away when
I knew I was going to
interview for the job, that oh,
tell me all about the
MCU and all of that.
And he was like, here's
a Marvel dictionary.
And I sort of
started from there.
So I knew of him, but
over that 14 months,
I really got to know him.
JOHN MAEDA: So a superhero.
HANNAH BEACHLER: Superhero.
JOHN MAEDA: Was your
reaction positive?
Yay, superhero!
Or superhero?
HANNAH BEACHLER: My reaction
to it being a superhero?
JOHN MAEDA: Yes.
HANNAH BEACHLER: I mean,
I was really super excited
because it was challenging.
I've done so many
things that are
so different from each
other that anything that
is going to challenge me,
I instantly want in on.
And working with Ryan
Coogler, the amazing director,
again, for the third
time was without question
I was going to be
involved with that.
So I never thought I
would ever do something
like a superhero movie.
That's not where I
saw my career going.
That's not what I
thought I wanted to do.
But then that's life.
It's not really what you
think in the beginning.
But as I started to get into it,
I was like, you know, why not?
I didn't think I would
do a boxing movie.
work with Beyoncé.
I didn't think I would
work on a little $1 million
movie that would win an Oscar.
So I don't generally
go into anything
thinking anything other than
how do I make this work?
How do I make this
the best it can be?
And for each film, it's
something different.
So for "Panther" there
was a reason behind it
for Ryan and I, and same
with all the other projects.
JOHN MAEDA: So you had to look
1,000 years in the future,
and you didn't come to Silicon
Valley to look at that future.
HANNAH BEACHLER: No.
JOHN MAEDA: Talk about that.
HANNAH BEACHLER:
Well, first I had
to look 1,000 years in the past.
That was a big
part of Wakanda was
the honoring of the
culture, and the tradition,
and the diaspora--
the African
diaspora-- that really
is what Wakanda is
representational of.
So I had to look
backwards because I
think the past is a
very important bridge
to what the future is.
And that needs
inclusion in design
in this world of what I was
doing for "Black Panther."
Looking into the
future, I didn't know--
and you know what?
Honestly, I didn't know
that Silicon Valley could
have helped me for my needs.
I didn't think that I was
going to find in there.
And honestly, I didn't
really know much about it.
I live in New Orleans.
It's a very small town.
I don't live in Los Angeles.
I don't live in New York.
I live in a place
where the population is
like 250,000 to 300,000 people.
I didn't know much
about Silicon Valley.
I kind knew what I saw on TV--
sounds familiar.
But I didn't really
know how that
could help me create
this technology which you
would think was kind of crazy.
Because what I
knew I needed to do
was evolve something that
Silicon Valley, to me, I felt
had no interest in,
which is this culture.
So there was-- you
know what I mean?
I felt like I kind of
had to give an autonomy
to this story and a narrative
that, at times, is restricted,
just in general, by society--
like the ability to tell--
a community's ability to
tell their own story, how
they want it told, and based
on what they want it based on.
So that was sort of me being
the person who made sure
that the representation of the
culture that we were digging
into, and creating a
fictional one on top of it,
stayed to what I
needed it to be.
And I didn't know that
Silicon Valley could help me.
Now, I did reach out
to a lot of experts
about all kinds of stuff--
geology, geography, archeology.
We talked to experts
in architecture
who were doing
future cities, people
who were sort of
architectural archaeologists
that could talk to us about
some of the architecture
of Pre-colonial
Sub-Saharan Africa.
And then of course,
going to South Africa,
traveling all over South
Africa for three weeks,
and sort of understanding that.
Because at the heart
of "Black Panther"
was the question of what
is it to be African?
And so that's sort
of why I felt like I
didn't want to go or need
to go to Silicon Valley.
I don't know-- that
is what it was like.
And I mean, that's honest.
That's the honest truth.
And because I was so
busy, I was like I'm just
going to have to do this.
I'm just going to have
to figure this one out.
And I didn't really know
1,000 years into the future.
Here's the thing--
it's hard enough
to go any amount into
the future and understand
what you'd think might happen
or how people would respond.
So I found myself getting
to this place where
I started thinking about
technology in the future, how
Wakanda would use technology.
Technically, "Black
Panther" is placed in 2018.
It's not sci-fi.
It felt sci-fi because Wakanda--
you know what I mean?
We have to remember,
it's not science fiction.
It's supposed to live in
this universe, which is 2018.
So I had to make sure it felt
grounded enough that people
weren't like, it's space.
But it also had to be advanced
enough where people thought,
maybe this is
something that's going
to come around in 50 years,
60 years, or something.
It's not impossible.
And then you had to add
sort of with the vibranium,
the fantasy of it all.
So you know, and I'm
rambling, so I don't even
know if I answered the question.
But that's sort of--
I might have lost myself.
JOHN MAEDA: Actually, when
you were describing that,
I remember walking my
mom out of the theater,
because she can't walk very
well because she has diabetes
and her feet are really--
it makes it hard.
So she's walking really slowly
and talking really slowly.
And I remember when we'd just
left the theater, she said,
you know, "Black Panther"
was so beautiful.
All the scenery, everything
And it's the thing
that stuck with her--
how beautiful the movie is.
And it's optimistic.
And so where did that
come from, and how were
you able to translate that?
HANNAH BEACHLER: I
mean, I like to do
things that are beautiful.
And I think that's another
part of "Black Panther,"
is changing this
idea of narrative,
of how we see things.
It was a challenge to
me of how I saw Africa,
what I thought about Africa.
Just because I'm
black, doesn't mean
I'm an expert on
African culture, right?
So I really had to dig in
and challenge myself about
like, OK, well, what do I think?
What are my biases?
What was I raised with?
From my American
experience, this
is a land that's
1,000 miles away.
And as far as I
know, my ancestry
begins and ends at slavery.
And then the culture
that came afterwards
was this bastardized
idea-- or we were told
it was a bastardized culture.
We're not African,
we're not American,
so it became this bastardized
culture in a sense.
And you go through all of
these different points in time
throughout American history.
So I needed to rediscover what
that was thousands of miles
away from where I live, and
how I'm connected to that.
Because, oftentimes, you
feel like the hyphenate
between the African
and American.
You're really not either one.
So it was what is
it to be African,
because this is a movie--
Wakanda is African.
It's not African-American.
And one of the little
things that Ryan
was so brilliant at doing in
the film with Killmonger's
character-- who's the villain,
if you haven't seen it.
Has everybody seen
"Black Panther?"
Is that a thing?
[APPLAUSE]
Awesome.
So Killmonger-- played by the
fabulous Michael B Jordan--
if you notice something
about him, it's his names.
And part of the reason behind
him having so many names
is because our American
ancestry is that we
have been given so many names.
We were Negroes.
We were black folk.
We were colored.
We were Afro-American.
We were African-American.
And that's sort of how
this has gone over time.
So what Ryan did was
he gave Michael Jordan
the N'Jadaka name.
But they also called him Erik.
They also called him Killmonger.
They also called
him Erik Stevens.
So he's that representation
of African-American never
having a true identity,
from different places
and different people call
him different things.
And that's the tie back.
And those are the
types of things
that we were trying to do.
That is a piece of
representation, in a sense.
And we'll get to
representation because I
think that's mostly what
we want to be talking about
is how that is so important
in "Black Panther"--
technologically, scientifically,
through your STEM, and then
also socially, and economically.
And so there are so many little
things that we did in there.
I mean, it goes so
deep into how we
brought in the representation.
And that was one of them.
And it was in such
a small story way
that you don't
even really realize
that's what's happening.
Because Shuri calls
him Erik Stevens.
T'Challa calls him N'Jadaka.
His father calls him--
Ross calls him Killmonger.
His father calls him Erik.
So it's everybody-- he
doesn't have an identity.
And he's going to Wakanda
to try to figure that out.
And that's sort of
the representation
of where we are as sort of the
"lost tribe" as we called it.
JOHN MAEDA: I'm such
a Ryan Coogler fan.
So I can see that detail.
I didn't see it until
you described it.
HANNAH BEACHLER:
The small detail.
JOHN MAEDA: When we
were talking last week
about representation--
HANNAH BEACHLER: Yes?
JOHN MAEDA: --you mentioned
the production designer,
Wynn Thomas.
And I looked up Wynn Thomas.
I hadn't heard of
his name before.
And he has credits for "Hidden
Figures," "A Beautiful Mind,"
"Analyze This," all
of Spike Lee's movies.
So you mentioned seeing him
on television or something?
HANNAH BEACHLER: I saw he was
nominated for an Academy Award
for "Mars Attack,"
the Tim Burton film.
And I happened to be watching
the Academy Awards that year,
and I was like, oh, who's
this black man doing
this thing that I want to do?
And that was really the first
time that I really saw that.
I was like, oh, my goodness.
What is this?
Because I had always been a big
fan of Bernardo Bertolucci--
who is an Italian director back
in the '50s, '60s, '70s, and
'80s--
and his designer,
Ferdinando Scarfiotti,
was someone who was really
a big influence to me,
was this Italian
man way back when.
But my design aesthetic is
highly influenced by his.
But seeing him never made me
feel like, eh, I can do that,
because he's this Italian guy.
Of course he can.
He's an Italian guy.
Like I'm this farm
girl from Ohio
who literally runs
around with bare feet
and riding my horse to the
store to get Jolly Ranchers when
I was like six.
How do I get to that?
How do I get to-- there
was no path for me there.
So I kind of started
thinking like what are some
of the other things that I
could do where there might be
a path that's still creative?
And that's how I had to think,
knowing that that wasn't
something that was for me.
But then when I saw Wynn, which
was much later in my life,
that's when I realized
like, you know what?
I can actually go for this.
I mean, that didn't actually
mean that I could go for it,
but seeing it certainly
made me feel that way.
And I took that chance.
And that gave me an opportunity
to get into this industry
and really go far.
I mean, as I got into
it, I realized like,
oh, this is really hard.
I'm the only one.
And I am the only one.
And that's a really
strange thing
to think that you are
the only black female who
does this, who does what
I do and at this level.
You know, there's
one other one--
Toni Barton.
And she's an art
director working
on television for Marvel.
And I kind of saw
her on Twitter,
and I was like, uh, I want
to be-- let's be friends.
And she's like, I
don't even know you.
And I'm like stalking
her on Twitter,
like, I want to be girlfriends.
And she's like, OK.
Maybe don't-- maybe
call my agent.
But we finally kind of--
like I broke her down.
And she finally decided
to be my friend.
And we're kind of besties.
Don't quote me.
And don't go up to
her and be like,
Hannah said you were besties,
because she'll be like,
I don't know who she is.
But that's-- you want
to find likeness.
You want to find relatability.
And when you look
at communities--
I think one of the
other things too
is when you look at communities
who are associated with not
having a lot of tech, and not
having access to a lot of tech,
and you start relating
your economic status
to your racial profile,
that all of a sudden--
especially in poverty--
the black community
becomes associated
with this idea
of not being tech
savvy or wanting tech
or having that type of thing
within their community.
And it's basically all
based on accessibility.
It's not there
because how many--
representation is
not just in front
of whatever it is or throwing
the pretty on it that
seems to be representing
a group or a culture,
but actually having
the voices creating it.
Is it-- you look at it like,
was it important for me
to be the production designer on
something like "Black Panther?"
Or the "Infinity War's"
designer, Charles Woods, would
he be able to have
then done that?
And so I do believe
that the representation
behind the camera--
I'll say, because
that's what I do--
I mean, behind the desk?
I don't-- do you guys stand?
I don't know.
JOHN MAEDA: Walk.
HANNAH BEACHLER: You
know what I'm saying?
Or however it goes, is as
important as creating an app
or creating something--
is specifically
having the voices
there that then
has the experience
in those communities.
Because you really don't
know what you don't know,
and that's what I learned
by going to Africa.
Like I don't know
what I don't know,
but I knew that I was going
to look at it with beauty.
I knew I was going to
look at it with the lens
of absolute modernism, and
beauty, and capability--
all the things that I wanted
to put into "Panther."
I wasn't looking
for the commercial
with the poverty-stricken
children.
I wasn't looking for
the things that we're
told the continent is.
I was looking for the
joy, and the pride,
and the dignity of the
people that lived there.
And that's the choice we
make for wherever we are.
Because I met people who lived
in the rural parts of Africa
just as much as people who
lived in the modern cities,
like Johannesburg,
and we were in Durban,
we were in Cape Town.
So it's-- you can see someone
dressed in their traditional
Zulu or traditional
Xhosa in the city,
just as much as you might
see that in the rural areas.
So I decided not only to
find myself and realize
that I think I've been
African this entire time,
but that I was determined to
find all the beautiful things
that I was told weren't there.
Because that then really came
back to who I am as a person.
It really related
back to who I am
and how I felt about myself,
and the confidence that I had.
So it all kind of-- like,
our fictional world building
bleeds back into our realities.
JOHN MAEDA: Could you just--
we have two minutes left.
Could you share a
non-fiction story
you shared with me that
moved me very much,
which was about the
director Ryan Coogler, who
I'm a huge fan of.
And I've always wanted
to-- in Silicon Valley,
we talk about leadership--
CEO, or the product
manager is the CEO
of the product, and
these CEOish things.
I think of Ryan Coogler
as one of the great CEOs
of our time in creatives.
You shared a story about him.
Could you talk about that?
HANNAH BEACHLER: When I
was talking to myself?
JOHN MAEDA: Yes.
HANNAH BEACHLER: So
you obviously know
I'm kind of weird.
So I'm going to tell this story.
Don't hold it against me.
But so we're working
on "Creed," and we're
tech scouting, which
is coming and going
to look at all these locations,
and you can spend all day.
And we had stopped
at this coffee shop.
And I got my coffee.
And everybody was
getting their coffee.
But I was kind of
working out a problem.
And when I'm trying to work out
a problem or solve a problem,
I talk out loud to myself,
because that's the best way
to do it for me, apparently.
And my friends and stuff
will like poke fun at me
like, oh, you're crazy.
You're talking to yourself.
And so sometimes I do it and I
don't even know I'm doing it.
So Ryan comes walking over
to me, and he was like,
are you talking to yourself?
And I was like a
little like, uh.
You know what I mean?
I know you and
love you, but yeah.
And the first thing he said--
he looked at me and he said,
that's the sign of a really
healthy mind and a really
intelligent person.
And he kind of turned
around and walked away.
And I was kind of like ready
to get the hit of like,
oh, you're crazy--
kind of funny joke, joke, but
a little bit like of a slight.
And that's not at all
where his mind came from.
It looked for the immediate
positive thing about the thing
that I was doing,
that sometimes people
think is weird or
could make you feel
a certain way about yourself
that eventually starts
beating you down and making--
defining who you are
because you're hearing
negative things about it.
That is who Ryan is.
He's the person that will
constantly lift people up,
will constantly-- and he
is not perfect, I promise.
There's days when I'm like,
please make a decision.
You have like two hours.
And he does all the
things that directors
do that can
completely bother you,
or things that are like amazing.
But he's the type of person--
like we would be on set
for Warrior Falls, which
was the big waterfall where
they had the big fight.
And he gathered us all
around in a big circle.
Some people were in the water.
And he really told us why
that scene was important.
This is before we
even started shooting.
He really started to
say why that scene was
important to him,
and really talked
about having all the fictional
tribes of Wakanda in one place
and represented by
all the references
that we used of the tribes--
the different tribes
in Sub-Saharan Africa.
And how that was a big part of
him, really feeling complete.
And you're holding hands and
he's telling us all of this,
and we're standing
in this circle,
and you just feel like you
can take on the entire world
at that point.
So that's who he is as a
director and my friend.
And he is a really
important voice
because his perspective
on anything and everything
is the most unique
perspective you will--
I promise you-- ever
hear from anybody.
If you ever get a
chance to talk to him,
talk to him because he
will turn a situation
and make you see it from a side
you were never maybe even meant
to see it from.
And all of a sudden,
your world opens up.
And so I can always--
and he would be standing here
going like, oh, please stop.
But he is really that great.
JOHN MAEDA: Wow, thanks
for sharing that story.
What a leader and
what a designer.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]